who is one person in this ensemble that
when you first read their role on the
page it became so much more than you
ever could have imagined that they
brought something out of it that you
never expected MJ you know because MJ is
the heart she's the matriarch and the
whole point is these are chosen families
they shouldn't have to carry the weight
and the burden of an entire culture
that's what I think is just so brilliant
about Blanca and one of the things that
I don't think the industry quite
understands you know because we live in
a in a world that is myopic very often
we live in a space where the playing
field is not level but we're all judged
as if it is what people don't get about
pose in general and this is for
everybody is that every one of those
young kids on that show are on
television and myself included aren't
being on television carrying a show as
regulars for the first time there's not
training schools they're not coming from
Juilliard they're not coming from Yale
they're not coming from you know New
York University grad school or Carnegie
Mellon like myself they're coming from
their communities they're walking off
the streets and delivering the
performances that they are delivering
sorry but none of y'all can touch that
none of y'all can touch the fact that MJ
Rodriguez is carrying this show on her
back like Jesus on the road to Damascus
with that cross you know it's like she
does have no training like that
she didn't come from none of that she
had a dream and she showed up and she's
delivering a performance like that
people don't really it's like they're
not really getting that part of it
they're not getting that part of it it's
like no she's delivering on it like I
watch her and I just it blows my mind
what she's doing on this show she's
carrying this show just like all them
other white ladies carry all those other
dramas she's carrying it just like that
without the luxury of having any
experience doing it has extremely well
said yeah you know it's like now you
it's like yeah I mean you know and I'm
the glossy one you know I'm the glossy
one I'm older more people know who I am
I'm the obvious one yes I guess and I've
worked hard and I deserved it blah blah
blah blah blah I couldn't do it without
her and this show would not exist
without her control grounding energy the
two of us are the grounding energy
together but in terms of the mother of
the house earth she the one that grounds
it you know she's so much of the heart
and she just oozes warmth and
inspiration it's just every single time
I walk away from an episode of pose
usually I feel motivated and inspired
because of how Blanca carries herself
and I think it's because of the purity
of MJ's performance and what she brings
to that role you talk about realness all
the time and I hope part of the reason
why that performance transcends the
screen it become so much more yeah you
know what it's interesting because it
challenges people to understand it
challenges people too
see another type of human being on the
planet that's a real human being that
none of y'all have ever met before so
you actually don't know how to
adjudicating they don't know how to
adjudicate the performance they don't
know because they don't know where it
comes from they don't know what the
history is they don't know anything
about this woman to be in the position
that she's in
none of y'all understand that none of
y'all you know and we're trying to show
it on screen you know but like that's
the performance she's delivering for me
she should be winning everything do you
think there's anything anybody can do to
kind of change that conversations
because I can definitely understand the
frustration here it's like I don't know
even even from like this angle to tell
to tell more of her story to put it out
there and awards campaigns more like
what what can we do to change that I
don't know I have no idea you know I'm
the kind of person where I learned early
on that like with as much of as awards
are good for this little gay boy you
know it's different for me than it is
for for my white counterparts they don't
need them I actually need them so that I
can be taken seriously I actually need
them so people will pay attention to me
it gives me power in a space where I
have been powerless for so long you know
we just have to stay focused on the work
we are making headway the fact that
posed exists at all you know I'm so
grateful to lived long enough to see
that
pulse there's no there's no context for
that for me it was never an option for
me that was not an option